we're renovating our 68 year old
family home on a budget
and I'm excited because today is the day our
kitchen finally gets her glow up
but I'm also oblivious to the minor shit storm
that may or may not be brewing
and I'm gonna cut a long story short here
but this kitchen is actually not that old
it's got great bones I'm just personally not
vibing the black and grey aesthetic
the kitchen is also on the shady side of the house
and I don't mean the side that my husband lives in
I mean the side that doesn't get a whole lot of natural light
so it's on the same side as the lounge if you
caught any of that room renovation
anyway
point being the light that it does get
is being absorbed by these dark finishes
making it feel a whole lot darker than it needs to be
so initially I started toying with the idea of maybe painting the tiles
maybe painting the bench and giving the space a bit of an aesthetic refresh
but also I give my kitchens a really hard life
I've got three children and I'm in this space all the time
so I didn't wanna have to turn around and
redo it in two years do you know what I mean
so one day like 10 months ago now
I went to go browse stone at Cosentino
and it turns out
you can't window shop for benchtops
without absolutely falling in love
and then I found a sink and a tap and some tiles that I love
and anyway - almost a year of manifestation later -
cut to: demolishing my kitchen
our fabricators were Architectural Stone and they came and measured up
and from there it was a waiting game
waiting for our install day
And they were kind enough to offer to help us remove our existing countertops
and honestly I'm bloody grateful that they did
because I don't have enough muscles for that job
quick side story but we spent a few years renovating our first home
and now we've been working on this house for a year
and if I've learnt just one thing
it said it's basically fkn impossible to do a room without a hiccup
so naturally this room was no exception
when it came time to install on the bench tops
unfortunately there was a hiccup
it's nobody's fault it just is what it is
and what it is is
dishes in the shower for the next 2 weeks
but the end is in sight, so come back for the update